XXX: when one X isn't enough.
Me, Kobe, LeBron, we're in another stratosphere.
I hear people talk about me so much.
And I forget, I really am great.
I'm just like you but ten times better.
When you think of MJ, what's the first thing that comes to your mind?
Me.
I know.
It's, like, people say, "Hey, you don't wanna swim with sharks,"...
...but I'm faster than sharks so it's not a big deal.
I think sometimes I hear people talk about me so much...
...that I forget, like, "Hey, open your ears, listen to these people."
They're smart.
They know you're great.
Why do companies ask me to push products?
Because I move products.
XXX: full of antioxidants when I need to make love to the camera.